martin short's president of the european
parliament winner of the Charla Manya
prize for work in the service of
European unification notably for making
Parliament more visible more
comprehensible and more accessible
syscon story he must meet one island for
Nina and that women are here but Duncan
it's consented for as many mouths to
feed on the DD beach they are Kevin
isn't us I'm all diminish our laws the
prize is named after shower romania king
of the franks the monarch who did more
to unify europe in the seven and 800 ad
than most before or after a vision mr.
shorts holds close the alehana leaped
the ironing and grandsons in would we be
frightened as it so Evan however passes
to the standard supervinlin on the
cylinder sue Scharffen Buckland in
Germany is Charlemagne use resting place
and it hosted many dignitaries previous
prize recipients president Hollande of
France and King Abdullah the second of
Jordan as Europe has shown as peace and
prosperity are secured only by
coexistence in a partnership of mutual
strengths based on mutual respect eldri
add puh-lease it willya ampullae in
protection yo mental mood ok you neyo
salle de la democracia mr. Schultz was
also cited promoting the ship itson
candidate or leading candidate system in
which the dominant political group in
parliament rather than EU leaders chose
the President of the European Commission
a change seen by many as a big advance
in European democracy
my